[Music]
welcome to grow your own food in your
own backyard and if you are new to my
Channel please consider subscribing and
don't forget to hit the like button it
is now for me to harvest my baby green
spinach and as you can see it is really
healthy and it is ready to be Harvest so
I just wanted to take you along and show
you how to harvest baby green spinach in
containers now there are two different
ways you can Harvest baby green spinach
you can actually cut it from the
outside and work your way
inward but oh my goodness it would take
forever for me to harvest each leaf and
work my way inward or another way to
harvest is just to cut it right off at
the top like
this now you don't want to cut it too
far from the base because you want to
come again so this is going to be cut
and come again and as you can see I
still am leaving a
base in the container as I'm harvesting
the spinach and I'm dropping a few on
the ground and you can see some of the
baby spinach is still being left and
this is a quicker
way so I'm going to go
ahead and harvest all this
[Music]
and again this is a quicker way to
harvest the baby green
spinach and I did not cut it all the way
down at the base because I want to be
able
to harvest my baby green spinach
again so if you would look inside the
container and you you can see there's
still a lot of the stems left which will
allow the spinach to grow
again so here's my first harvest of the
baby green
spinach and I am growing baby green
spinach which is a cool season crop in
the dead of Summer and you would ask how
am I doing this let me show you I have a
screen that I put over the container
like
this and I have
two large steaks on the end very thin
that I hold up and then I curl these
down and and um and um clip them and
then I also clip the sides over here
this container of baby green spinach
only gets Morning Sun
about 11:00 I know this my patio is no
longer receiving Sun so it's getting
Morning Sun and it's getting filter sun
it's allowing me to grow a cool seasoned
crop in the middle of the summer it is
now July 1st and as you can see I just
have a large bowl of spinach that I just
Harvest another benefit of using a shade
mesh covers is it keeps the insects off
the spinach the air wigs the butterflies
that want to lay their eggs on the Brasa
crops it serves many purposes and so it
allows me to be able to harvest grow and
harvest baby green spinach for the
remainder of the summer I have about
another
week before this spinach grows
again and allows me to harvest and
hopefully I may be able to get a third
Harvest before the end of the season so
hopefully in the next 7 days I should
have another container full of spinach
and therefore I am going to fix a
spinach salad for dinner
tonight I hope you enjoy the tips thank
you for watching and don't forget to hit
the like button
[Music]
oh